[Music]
[Applause]
did we decide on a poll question Seaton
before I get to Pat 40.
yeah Dan we've decided to go with uh
college football is currently moving in
a good direction or terrible Direction
and that with that we bring in pad 40
senior writer from Sports illustrative
we'll start you with a heavy question
there we headed in a good direction or a
bad Direction
oh put me down is terrible I think this
is uh really catastrophically bad
short-sighted greedy uh ultimately
disastrous but that's kind of par for
the course the course we've been on for
a while okay how does this affect the
fan
well if you're a fan of say West Coast
Football if you live in California
Oregon or Washington congratulations
enjoy your easy commutes to see your
team play in College Park Maryland State
College Pennsylvania
Piscataway New Jersey uh cherish those
long-held rivalries there you don't get
to play Oregon State or Washington State
anymore you don't get to play caler
Stanford if you're USC or UCLA but you
do get to play Iowa and Illinois and
Nebraska that's what you've always
wanted right so you get that for the fan
is uh you're gonna probably pay more for
tickets uh it's just all around it's
just your team's gonna win less as well
there's that so it's all good
um
I guess tell me if you you buy into this
um it feels like the schools in the
Pac-12 are waiting for other schools to
make an announcement so you're not the
bad guy who took down the path if you're
the Arizona schools if you want to join
the Big 12 but you don't want to leave
until Oregon and Washington go to the
Big Ten how's that sound
yeah I think there's definitely an
element of that although we might have
pushed past that now to the point of
like oh who cares it's all going to
collapse does it really matter who goes
first okay
I think there's still there's a reason
Oregon I'm sorry the Arizona Board of
Regents are meeting at 6 30 Pacific
today that's late that gives Oregon to
Washington plenty of time to pull the
rip cord in case they want to beat him
to it and go to the pac-10 or the Big
Ten so I I think nobody wants that blood
on their hands but there's going to be
so much blood in the end that it's not
really gonna like the crime scene is
going to be so riddled with hand prints
who's going to know who's were first but
are we looking at a Big Ten East and a
big ten west
uh it's entirely possible you know we'll
see how they're going to work this out
they're obviously if you're if Oregon
and Washington do go then you've got
four out Far West you know maybe you're
looking at more of a pod sort of system
uh as opposed to just two divisions the
funny thing is everybody had just gotten
rid of Divisions yeah but it was just uh
we don't like division we don't want
them they don't help us with our
championship game they're gonna have to
go back to some sort of regional
delineation it doesn't make sense and
good luck trying to schedule 18 teams
we're going to be playing games all over
the map
also now we're hearing Florida state
which I think Florida state has always
viewed themselves as bigger and better
than the ACC Clemson views himself
probably bigger and better than the ACC
but I don't know how they can get out of
their TV deals if they want to go into
the SEC or whatever their strategy is
going to be so what do you see with
Clemson and Florida State
yeah that's that's the big sticking
point there I mean Florida State all but
seceded from the Union yesterday I mean
the president the trustees like we're
out we don't like it here we're leaving
well where are you going where are you
going I don't see the SEC jumping up and
down saying yeah we'll we'll help you
break a 12-year grant of rights 13 years
still right now and get in the middle of
that ridiculous legal battle and then
bring you in over Florida's dead body I
mean there's some issues there the big
tent is going to go to 18. I don't see
them you know bending over backwards to
try to help Florida State in this
situation so I don't know whether that
was just a a temper tantrum they felt
like they needed to have or that's
negotiating for an even higher cut of
the revenue or what but I they say that
they can handle them or figure out way
out of the grander rights let's see it
pat 40 a senior writer for Sports
Illustrated that brings us to Notre Dame
give me the scenario where Notre Dame
would be I don't want to say forced to
join the Big Ten but encouraged to join
the Big Ten
well they're they're constantly
encouraged I mean like the Big Ten is
you know kind of just extended the open
invitation there's a candle in the
window lit for Notre Dame at all times
um but I don't think any of this would
necessarily force their hand now we'll
see they've still got their own uh
negotiations to do and come up with
their own meteorites but everything ever
since I've gotten from Notre Dame is
that they feel like they're gonna end up
in a good place uh and be able to remain
independent now if literally the rest of
the map falls apart if the ACC in
particular falls apart in short order
that Notre Dame has enough ties there
that that could get problematic for them
and push them towards the Big Ten but
for now I still think Notre Dame wants
to and can stay put as an independent
but what if you have and I don't know
how many years down the road but let's
say we have the top 50 schools the
revenue schools for football and they
decide that okay we're gonna have you
know the NFL model and Notre Dame can't
play those teams now you're now you're
saying to Notre Dame you know these are
this schedule is against these teams who
are in our conference in our league and
Notre Dame would be playing Air Force
and Army and who else BC and they they'd
run out run out of these quality
opponents that we've you know grown to
love that there's rivalries here
yeah no I mean there I mean that's that
is the Doomsday scenario for them and
now it would take a lot to get to that
point the Big Ten would have to kick
members out the SEC would have to kick
members out and if you talk to them now
I mean look everything ends up being
negotiable right I mean nobody would
have ever thought that USC and UCLA
would end up in the Big Ten so
everything can happen but you talk to
those people in those conferences
they're like man we do not want to be
the people that tell Purdue you have to
leave you know or tell Mississippi you
have to leave so that's that is down the
roadways if it does come to that yes
Notre Dame's out of real estate they
have been painted into a corner and they
would have to go but who knows when that
would be if I gave you Caleb Williams or
the field for the Heisman
boy it's tough to repeat so
once so I'm gonna I'm gonna take the
field just just on the odds that uh it's
very tough to do now I do think he's the
best player
um and I think he's fantastic I think
he's gonna be the number one draft pick
but just on the fact that Archie Griffin
stands alone is the only person to ever
do it in Heisman history I'll take the
field
the most famous player in college
football is not even going to start this
year for Texas with Arch Manning you
know Quinn healers who is listed as one
of the top five Heisman candidates and
Arch is just gonna did was this the game
plan did Texas know that Quinn yours was
going to be their starter and did Arch
know that he wasn't going to start going
in his first year
I mean I think they went into the
arrangement when he showed up on campus
in January with a fairly good
understanding Quinn yours was the guy
and he would have to be very good to
beat him out and I think Arch's family
was just like fine we are not in a rush
here he needs to red shirt let him red
shirt you know this is not the Mannings
are not going into this saying we need
this this and this right away they're
like no that I mean Cooper his dad is uh
I think almost relieved that he can
start his college career without being
immediately thrust into that Spotlight
if we speak in two weeks what do you
think we're talking about
uh we're talking about an 18 team Big
Ten we are talking about a a
non-existent Pac-12 talking about a 16
team Big 12 and almost none of that's
actually going to matter because George
is probably going to win
[Laughter]
when did it change Pat
when did college football get to in and
I don't know when but I did have a coach
say if we knew as the SEC schools were
interested in somebody we backed away
um when Missouri and a m went to the SEC
that was 12 years ago I believe so I
don't know when all of a sudden it
started to change where things were
reshaped
you know I mean it's funny you can go
back and find realignments spasms and
changes going back to the 30s probably
even before that so I mean it's it's
happened periodically throughout time
but
1984 the NCAA loses its contract
Monopoly on TV and all of a sudden
everybody can get a TV contract all the
conferences and then that really started
to change the economics of everything
and it started to change the allegiances
to a degree and then obviously okay the
SEC went to 12 added South Carolina and
Arkansas I did a championship game then
whoa everybody wants a championship game
so that happened and then I think the
big really big Catalyst Dan was 2009
10-11 in there when the Big 12 got rated
and the and the Big East was was poached
to death and when it suddenly made sense
to people for West Virginia to be in the
same conference with Texas Tech that's
when it's like okay it just doesn't
matter geography doesn't matter nothing
matters but how we can make the most TV
money
good to talk to you stay busy no problem
no danger of that thank you uh Pat 40
Sports Illustrated senior writer yeah I
don't want to be the sky is falling but
I I do want to give you a heads up the
sky is moving
maybe not falling but man it looks
ominous it just does